the hit man's bodyguard star samuel
l.jackson is one of the world's most
notorious hitman and Ryan Reynolds as
his bodyguard who has to get him to
testify in court against the evil
dictator played by Gary Oldman and along
the way they both get shot at hundreds
of times and possibly learned that they
could be good buddies maybe this film
was directed by Patrick Hughes who's
less than was The Expendables 3 and his
action sequences here have improved a
lot since that film they're more
believable there's less CGI they're also
edited better there's a really great
sequence for Ryan Reynolds has to fend
off some thug and he uses all different
types of things you can find in this
tool shop it was a lot of fun and that's
really my best way to describe this
entire film it's just fun it's a fairly
ridiculous movie that really makes no
sense whenever it tries to be really big
and sometimes gets more serious than it
needs to be it rarely exceeds its
boundaries as an action comedy and when
it sticks to Jackson and Reynolds just
bickering back and forth it works
Sam Jackson is in prime
form and Ryan Reynolds is in prime I'm
Canadian form they're both good if you
like their public personas they've
created for themselves you're going to
enjoy their characters even though their
characters are pretty thin because they
really are playing a sort of exaggerated
version of their public persona but if
you're fine with that and I feel like
most people who build to see the Hitman
The Bodyguard are going to be and you're
probably not going to be too bothered by
that a big surprise in this movie with
Salma Hayek who I didn't even know
what's in the film she plays the
incarcerated wife of Sam Jackson's
character who says she's innocent but
when you learn if her past you're like
he should probably be in jail actually
she was hilarious there's some really
great stuff they do with her even though
she doesn't get that much screen time
but that's probably a good thing I feel
like if that character was in the film
too much she would start to wear on your
nerves but she was in it for just the
right amount of time and her scenes were
truly funny but the film is pretty
uneven it bounces back and forth from
some really absurd comedy to some
equally absurd action but also some
darker aspects that didn't feel like
they fit in with the movie and it also
goes on a little too long I would say
about 15 minutes too long you think it's
going to end
there's more and gary oldman seems like
he's in a completely different movie
he's given a really good classic Gary
Oldman bad guy performance think Air
Force One but it just feels like he's in
a different movie sometimes and that
comes down to the writing which as I
said is uneven the performers and the
director are doing a pretty good job
here this is a perfectly enjoyable movie
that I think the majority who go to it
are going to have fun with I'm going to
give the hit man's bodyguard of being -
guys thank you so much as always for
watching look forward to more Stephen
King reviews this weekend I have some
pretty exciting stuff we've worked on
that I can't wait to share with you as
always you're the best if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
menage
[Music]